to italy now where pope francis is in
the central italian town of l'aquila on
a closely watched visit as part of his
trip he got a look for himself at
reconstruction work following the 2009
earthquake which badly damaged many of
the region's buildings the main event on
the pope's itinerary was celebrating
mass at a pilgrimage church the visit to
la cuella comes a day after francis
appointed 20 new cardinals many of whom
may one day help chose his successor
for more i'm joined now here in the
studio by dw religious affairs
correspondent martin gak and that
actually raises quite a lot of questions
so could you perhaps tell us i mean
during mass the pope said that
relinquishing power was a sign of
humility
this is surely somehow adding to
speculation about his future
indeed so there's been
quite a bit of speculation quite a bit
of rumor particularly in specialized
specialized press about the possibility
of him essentially stepping back
stepping out of the papacy uh the visit
to l'aquila is itself quite significant
because actually in l'aquila
one of the only popes that actually has
resigned his position
and during the the homily he actually
did say that relinquishing power uh is
indeed a form of humility and it's an
expression of godliness
this will not help settle rumors as a
matter of fact we'll probably accelerate
the rumor machine
and this comes directly in the heels of
this concept story which is happening
actually pretty much right now it will
continue tomorrow and the day after in
which 20 new cardinals many of them
quite aligned with the both political
and ideological if not theological
intuitions had been actually
brought into the fault of the church and
become potential electors in the
choosing of the next pope so what does
this tell us about the future of the
church
it's actually a very good question it's
really quite difficult to sort of
pinpoint what is that happens sort of
from here on particularly because
there's been a very strong confrontation
between
very conservative sectors of the church
particularly led by the anglo-saxon
world the u.s and australia play sort of
a really significant role
and essentially the papacy which has
taken a much more
integrative if not sort of commitment
committed to diversity
many of the people that were now made
cardinals are people that come from
fairly unusual places for instance goa
where there's been for 450 years sort of
membership of the church but actually no
cardinal
and as a matter of fact people that
generally belong to the basis of the
church and do not really came coming to
the church as part of
sort of its hierarchy so it's very
likely that the next conclave will see
many of these voices represented in ways
that they had not been before all right
martin gag dw religious affairs
correspondent thank you so much for that
you're welcome
you